et paysages à couper le souffle des
traditions lointaine et un mode de vie
différent
habitués aux excursions la photographe
bernadette chenu hardy nous invite ce
mois ci au voyage
direction le vietnam le vietnam c'est un
pays qui m'a entraîné dans les voyages
quand j'étais gamine sur les bancs de
l'école et que j'ai voulu dont j'ai rêvé
et
j'ai voulu en faire ancrer des histoires
part à travers mes photographies
au total une soixantaine de photos
retracent des scènes du quotidien mais
aussi la rencontre avec le peuple hmong
du nord du vietnam
des portraits d'hommes de femmes mais
surtout d'enfants c'est parce que les
enfants de l'ethnie hmong représente une
à la fois un grand bonheur certes mais
aussi une fierté de pérenniser les
l'héritage familial très très important
et respecté dans les ethnies en couleur
ou noir et blanc derrière chaque cliché
une émotion une histoire comme sur cette
photo d'une femme vivant du ramassage de
cartons j'avais juste envie de l'aider
je ne connaîtrais jamais son nom il
connaîtra jamais le mien mais il a eu
des regards de sympathie et
émotionnellement très intense une
volonté de partage et de découverte qui
habite également la responsable de la
bibliothèque beaulieu un espace devenu
lieu d'exposition dans un quartier
populaire
on a vécu une année difficile tout mon
année de repli de contraintes et donc
cette exposition c'était l'occasion
d'offrir une petite respiration
aujourd'hui quartier et puis aussi aux
gens qui ne sont pas du quartier
d'ouvrir un petit peu d'offrir une
fenêtre ouverte sur le monde tout
simplement vietnam peuple du mékong
une exposition à découvrir jusqu'au 2
juillet à château